lawmakers have come down hard on Clark
County School leaders for student
performance we have obtained details on
how CCSD students scored on AP exams a
news now education reporter Joshua
peguero shows the wide gap between
schools
this data from the state shows the
schools where kids had the worst AP exam
scores at three and above is considered
passing and as you can see here there
are a lot of ones and twos a Canyon
Springs High School
589 exams were taken 531 failed that's
around 10 percent of students passing
other schools with high number of
failures Cheyenne Clark El Dorado
Western and Mojave a kid who gets a one
really you know you could say they
didn't put a lot of effort into it and
maybe they weren't prepared maybe the
teacher didn't do what they were
supposed to do this is James terranova's
first year teaching AP US History at
Canyon Springs Terra Nova was surprised
by the low scores you know I gave every
kid one of these AP U.S history Canyon
Springs nolita tumeri which means do not
be afraid in Latin because I don't want
them to be afraid of the test only 58
students passed that Canyon who took
last year's AP exams Terra Nova says
their needs to be accountability for low
test scores they really want to succeed
on these tests and if we're not paying
attention to teachers who have 80 or 90
percent of their kids failing then uh
we're doing the kids a disservice there
are standout CCSD schools where students
scored very well Coronado High is one
example Marie porcini is graduating this
year and going to attend Boston
University I've done much better taking
the night before off just calming myself
down watching a movie thinking about
something else Puccini credits her
teachers for passing I don't think I'd
be able to do it without those teachers
they are the most valuable resellers of
Coronado and they care so much about
their students as I just mentioned
Coronado students scored highest on APA
exams and nearly 1400 exams taken 1 300
scored a three or above rounding out the
top scores Advanced Technologies Academy
Arbor View green Ali Clark also and West
career and Tech Academy back to you guys